chris hogan here i've spent so much time
on the road and talked with a lot of
people and the millionaire success
stories that I run into might surprise
you whether I'm at an event or talking
on my podcast one thing has become clear
most people have no idea what a
self-made millionaire really looks like
you're gonna get a glimpse into the life
of a self-made millionaire
these folks are hard at work you don't
want to miss it people this is
millionaire my name is Andy I'm 47 years
old I live in the Indianapolis area I am
a single father I am an engineer I've
got a degree in engineering from Purdue
University today my worth is 3.7 million
dollars today that I personally
cherished earning my own money to get
things that I want so I started cutting
grass at age 12 and my goal at the time
was to make $200 that summer 200 was
blown away I think I ended up making
over $1,000 that summer and it really
opened my eyes that doesn't matter how
old you are you can make money but more
importantly I think goal setting set in
in my teens my dad took over the family
business and he is an aggressive
risk-taking guy when you run a business
you can't have a gamblers mentality and
long story short through the early 80s
the family business went away and it
wasn't devastating because it definitely
was a character builder to go from
having something to honestly just live
in an apartment you know
at 19 years old I had a person asked me
to write down my goals and one of those
was I actually wrote down the age I
wanted to be become a millionaire when
you set a goal and you write it down it
makes it stays in your mind
I remember that piece of paper it was a
little probably 6 by 4 yellow piece of
paper I wrote down those life goals at
19 and writing those things down was Pat
were very powerful in the first couple
years out of college I just enjoyed
making 30 grand a year and which was a
tremendous amount of money when you come
out of college and were broke for so
many years I am where I am not cuz I
made the money because I don't consider
that I make a lot of money
it's just I've invested over a long
period of time and I'm always looking
for opportunities when I first started
getting money motivated in my 20s you
know I was buying into the on wanna I
want a nice car and a big house and a
boat but it is I've matured in this
journey it was more about the freedom I
just wanted financial stability and
peace of mind and not have to go through
the stress of what we went through when
everything went away so I started
looking for opportunities outside of
nine-to-five to make more income mutual
fund program where they would just
immediately draft out of your account
each month the beginning a month most
people like to say Oh at the end of the
month I'll put some money away in
savings or investments in there's always
more months than money as they say pay
yourself first at the beginning of the
month when you get your income or your
check you put a set amount away mid to
late months sometimes I ran out of money
it will force you to figure out the rest
of the month when I started practicing
to pay yourself first principle I want
to draft it out as much as I could and
be a little uncomfortable but not
worried that the month was gonna run out
so I started doing that and that amount
that I kept putting away each month in
addition to the 401k and they did the
traditional 3 percent match and it just
continued to go up and up I'm in my 20s
at the time and right about that time I
met my my wife is we had exactly the
same mentality we bought used cars we
bought used furniture we we put all the
money we could
away it was fun to us just to see how
much we could we could save and invest
what I've discovered through my journey
is that successful people that do it on
their own just they're just
down-to-earth people if you approach
them talk to him they'll help you and
that's kind of why I'm doing this
segment now because I my goal is to
teach people what was taught to me by
people who took time
[Music]
I started reading books about real
estate investing my wife at the time was
battling cancer and one of the dreams we
had was to buy a lake house didn't have
to be big and fancy the more rustic and
cabanne it is the better I thought well
if I'm ever gonna do this now's the time
so I ended up buying a lake house that
was a blessing I can't I can't explain
any other way it's my wife was dying she
so that lake house means a lot to me
well that place is now a income source
for me and I've got people who love
living there they're taking care of it
I'm consider myself a real estate
investor and it's I need a knock on wood
it's going well money to me is just it's
a it's a tool I'm just a steward and
with that money I've made I've been able
to help a lot of people I helped put a
woman through college I helped a friend
buy a house I've helped another friend
buy a car personally I have an affinity
for music royalties because I played
music I love music I've actually put a
company together of like-minded
investors and we are looking to buy
music royalty packages it's it's music
and investing combined it's it's almost
like surreal to be honest with you you
have to find either books or people you
have to immerse yourself and you have to
get your mind set that it's possible
honestly I feel like I'm a student of
money because every day I I read me the
most important thing is do something
even if it's small what I did when I was
probably 25 or 26 when I learned pay
yourself first principle I just went on
the internet and found a company that
offers mutual funds you can just get an
index mutual fund or there's a lot of
other good ones even if it's $50 a month
just start just set it up and it's so
easy with today's transaction they just
pull $50 out each month and from there
it can grow
the challenges I faced when you're gonna
get a new car you guys eat at that
restaurant I mean those things were real
I heard them a lot of those people are
gonna probably watch this I'm not
laughing at them I'm just like it worked
[Music]
[Music]